PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Hi,
I'm Priyanka Vergadia.
And this is AI
Simplified, where we
learn to make our data useful.
We're helping an
imaginary company
that is in the process of
building their machine learning
workflow.
And to accelerate
AI innovation, they
are looking at Vertex
AI, which provides
tools for every step of the
machine learning workflow,
from managing data sets, to
different ways of training
the model,
evaluating, deploying,
and making predictions.
In the previous
episode, we started
by looking at the first part of
any ML project, the data sets.
Vertex AI supports managed data
sets for image, tabular, text,
and video data.
In this episode, let's move
further in the ML workflow
and talk about building
and training the models.
The managed data sets we
created earlier feed directly
into the model
building and training.
Although you can bring
external data sets
while building the
model, managed data sets
bring some added
benefits as I laid out
in the previous episode.
We have two options
to train the model.
We can use AutoML which allows
us to create high quality
custom models with minimal
effort and machine learning
expertise.
And the second option is to
write custom model training
code, where you can
run custom training
applications in the cloud
using pre-built containers
of your own.
Now when should you write
your own model code and then
should you choose AutoML?
It depends.
So let's see.
If your use case fits a
supported AutoML offering,
then starting with
AutoML is a great choice.
And these use cases include
cases where you have images,
or video classification,
or object
detection, text classification,
entity extraction
from the text, sentiment
analysis of text,
tabular regression,
and classification.
But if it does not fit
any of those categories,
or your model takes some
mixed input type, such
as you have images
and then the metadata
is in the form of text,
then it makes sense
to use custom model.
The other technical
factor could be
that you have specific
requirements for the underlying
model if you need
control over your model's
architecture, framework, or
the exported model assets.
For example, maybe
your model needs
to be built in
TensorFlow or PyTorch.
Then you use custom model.
Otherwise, for the basic
use cases, just use AutoML.
The next factor could
be how experienced
is your team with ML and AI.
If you have a team with limited
machine learning expertise
in building custom models,
then exploring AutoML
makes sense before looking
into the custom model code
because it is the
lowest barrier to entry.
Another deciding factor
could be your team size.
Now if you have a small data
science team and less machine
learning expertise in
that team, it perhaps
makes more sense to work with
AutoML because custom model
code would require more
time and maintenance.
And use AutoML if you want to
develop a quick initial model
to be used as a baseline
or a proof of concept,
which could eventually end up
being your production model.
But if you are looking to
improve on your existing
baseline, or
heuristics, then you
might want to write
your own custom model
to test out the possibilities.
Hopefully, these
factors have clarified
which path to take when it
comes to building the models.
Now let's see how to build
and train the AutoML model
using Vertex AI.
With that, onto the
Google Cloud console.
We learned how to create data
sets in the previous episode.
But for the sake
of completeness,
let's create a data set.
In this example, we're
using credit card fraud
detection data set
available on BigQuery
public data sets to
create a credit card fraud
detection model.
I have included the link to
this data set below if you
would like to follow along.
Once the data is uploaded,
we can analyze our data
in the rows and columns.
Right from the data
set details page,
we can select Train New
Model, define our objective,
which is classification here
since we are labeling examples
as either fraudulent
or non fraudulent.
This is where you
decide whether you
want to use AutoML
or custom training.
In this video, we're
focusing on AutoML.
So we will select that.
Stay tuned for the
next episode, where
I will cover a custom model.
Next, we give our model a name.
Under the Target
column, we select Class.
This is an integer
indicating whether or not
a particular transaction was
fraudulent, zero for non fraud,
and one for fraud.
In the advanced options, you can
specify a specific train test
split if you don't want Vertex
AI to handle that automatically
for you.
In this case, we're using
the random assignment.
But you can also
specify this manually
when you upload a
CSV of your data.
Or you can have the data
split chronologically
if it has a time column.
In the Choose Training
Options section,
we will go to the
Advanced option.
And since this data is heavily
imbalanced, less than 1%
of the data here contains
fraudulent transactions,
we will choose the
AUC PRC option,
which will maximize
precision recall for the less
common class.
In this case, we care more
about ensuring our model
can classify fraudulent
transactions correctly.
Now the last step is
compute and pricing.
Here we enter one as the number
of compute hours for our budget
and leave early
stopping enabled.
Training your AutoML
model for one compute hour
is typically a good start for
understanding whether there
is a relationship between the
features and labels you've
selected.
From there, you can
modify your features
and train for more time to
improve model performance.
Then we are ready
to start training.
From here, we can leave the
UI and will get an email when
our training job completes.
All right.
So our model is ready.
Let's explore the model
evaluation metrics.
We head to our Model
tab and evaluate
the model we just trained.
There are many
evaluation metrics here.
We will focus on two, the
confusion matrix, and feature
importance.
A confusion matrix tells us
the percentage of examples
from each class in our test
set that our model predicted
correctly.
In the case of an
imbalanced data
set like the one we're
dealing with here,
this is a better measure
of our model's performance
than overall accuracy.
Remember that less than 1% of
the examples in our data set
were fraudulent transactions.
So if our model accuracy is
99%, there is a good chance
that it's just randomly guessing
the non fraudulent class 99%
of the time.
That's why looking at our
model's accuracy for each class
is a better metric here.
The confusion matrix shows
that our initial model
is able to classify 85%
of the fraudulent examples
in our test set correctly.
This is pretty good,
especially considering
our significant
data set imbalance.
Next, we could try training our
model for more compute hours,
or gathering more training data
to see if we can improve that
from this 85%.
Now this shows us
the features that
provided the biggest
signal to our model
when making predictions.
The feature
importance is one type
of explainable AI, a field
that includes various methods
for getting more insight into
how animal model is making
predictions.
The feature importance chart
is calculated as an aggregate
by looking at all of our model's
predictions on our test set.
It shows us the most
important features
across a batch of examples.
This chart would
be more exciting
if most of the features in our
data set were not obscured.
We might learn, for example,
that the type of transaction,
transfer, deposit, et
cetera can be the biggest
indicators of fraud.
In a real world scenario,
these feature importance values
could be used to help
us improve our model
and to have more confidence
in its prediction.
We might decide to remove
the least important features
next time we train a
model, or to combine
two of our more significant
features into a feature cross
to see if this improves
our model's performance.
We are looking at feature
importance across a batch here.
But we can also get
feature importance
for individual
predictions in Vertex AI.
And we'll see how to do that
once we've deployed our model.
Now that we have trained
model, the next step
is to create an
endpoint in Vertex AI.
A model resource in Vertex AI
can have multiple endpoints
associated with it.
And you can split traffic
between endpoints.
On our model page, there
is Deploy and Test tab.
There we click
Deploy To Endpoint.
Give your endpoint a name
like fraud version one or two.
And then leave the traffic
splitting settings as is.
And then select a machine type
for your model deployment.
We used an n1-highcpu-2
here but you
can choose whichever
machine type you would like,
including one with GPUs.
Then select Done
and click Continue.
Leave the selected
location settings as is
and then click Deploy.
Your endpoint will take
a few minutes to deploy.
When it is completed, you
will see a green checkmark
next to it just like
my version one here.
Now we are ready
to get predictions
on our deployed model.
There are a few options for
getting model predictions,
the UI and the API.
Let's check out both one by one.
On your model page where
your endpoint is shown,
scroll down to the Test
Your Model section.
Here, Vertex AI has
chosen random values
for each of our model's
features that we can
use to get a test prediction.
You're welcome to change
these values if you like
and then scroll down to
the bottom of the page
and select Predict.
In the prediction
results section,
you should see your models
predicted percentage
for each class.
A confidence score of 0.99
for class zero for example
means that our model thinks this
example is 99% non fraudulent.
The UI is a great way to make
sure the deployed endpoint is
working as expected.
But chances are
that you will want
to get prediction dynamically
via a REST API call.
To show you how to get
model predictions here,
let's set up a notebook.
For that, we navigate
to Notebooks option
and select TensorFlow
Without GPUs.
Once created, open
the notebook instance.
And then we open Python 3
notebook form the launcher.
In the notebook, we run
the command in a cell
to install the Vertex AI SDK.
And below that, we add and
run a new cell and the example
from our test set.
Next, we need to create
the endpoint object
and then change the endpoint
ID and project number
to your specific endpoint.
You can get the endpoint from
the URL and the project ID
from the project dashboard.
We use that to make a prediction
request to our endpoint.
And we see our prediction
around 0.99 for the zero class,
which means the
model thinks there
is a 99% chance this
transaction is non fraudulent.
With that, we've learned
about the two options
to train our models in Vertex
AI, AutoML and custom training,
and when to use which one.
Then we went into the console
and trained an ML model
from scratch.
In the next episode
of AI Simplified,
we will look at building
and training a custom model.
In the meantime, let's
continue our discussion
in the comments below.
And don't forget to
like and subscribe
to catch that next episode.